- What's that?
What's that, right there?
SHANNON: That would be--
MIKE: Two bikes.
- --two motorcycles.
Do we want to talk to him?
- Well, I don't know.
You're the bike guy.
You tell me.
Do we want to talk to him?
Yeah, let's talk to him.
Let's just get out
of this damn vehicle.
Listen, I just want to
get out of the truck.
Whatever.
MIKE: I'm over sitting
in a truck with you.
I ain't nothing but a tag-along.
I might as well be holding
your pocket right now.
We'll just-- there you go.
Does that feel better for you?
That doesn't look right.
What's going on man?
I'm Shannon.
Nice to meet you.
- Vat.
- Mike.
Good to meet you, brother.
SHANNON: Nice to meet you.
Are any of these for sale?
Just this one.
It's a '88, S and
S, fishtails on it.
'88 Harley.
MIKE: Wow.
MIKE: (VOICEOVER)
Harley Davidson
holds the trademark
on the term "softail."
But like roller
blades and Kleenex,
it becomes a commonplace
term for any bike
that has a hidden
suspension in the rear.
Harley Davidson obtained a
patent for the first softails
in 1982.
And they released
the FXSTC in 1984.
It revolutionized the
motorcycle industry.
These bikes kept the look
of the rigid hardtails,
with much more comfortable
ride for your backside.
Can you tell me
anything about it?
I've had it since '89.
It's a carbureted bike--
put a custom paint job on it.
What you looking at?
That tanks-- did
you stretch them out?
I actually hand sanded them
and stretched the tanks--
had a buddy of mine
paint them for me.
Put a little skulls
action in there.
SHANNON: Those are
like five gallon tanks.
They're big tanks.
MIKE: That's what I'm saying.
They're so wide.
5.3.
MIKE: Damn.
So these are original miles?
3131?
VET: Yes sir.
Yes sir.
SHANNON: Wow.
So is the engine
stock-- bone stock?
Engine's pretty much stock.
The only thing I
did to the engine--
I had it reject it.
I put a S and S
carburetor on it.
I put some drag pipes on it.
And pretty much that's it.
- So this thing--
I mean, it runs and everything?
Everything's good to go?
Yeah.
It runs like a rocket.
Runs like a rocket.
Start it up, man.
[engine starting]
That's what I'm
talking, babies.
Drag pipe.
They hear you coming, but
you ain't going to hit.
Hey, it does sound good.
It sounds good.
You don't like it that loud.
I'm going to be
the brokenhearted
if you guys actually buy it.
So what do you think, fellas?
- Would you take 45?
- No.
SHANNON: Cash?
- Definitely not.
Definitely not.
No way.
MIKE: Stop insulting the man.
55?
It's more than that in parts.
52, and you got
yourself a deal.
Um, done.
Done.
Cool.
Well, don't cry now.
Don't cry.
I'm totally going to
cry man, are kidding me?
SHANNON: Don't cry.
I've had so many
stories on this thing.
All right, man.
I appreciate it.
Thank you.
Thank you bro.
And I will be back with your
cash to get you all situated.
All right, appreciate it.
Oh, man.
I don't want to see
a grown man cry.
Vet and that bike have obviously
been through some things
together.
He's off to Washington.
We will take good care of
his bike here in Vegas.
It's a win-win for everybody,
but he gonna cry in the house.
So we'll just go get his
money, come back, pick it up.
Is that cool?
I really don't care.
What do you mean
you don't care?
You should care.
You're not happy we
bought something cool?
I'm happy that
you bought a bike,
and we're going to
go back to the shop.
I'm just happy I'm going
to get-- be able to get
back out of the truck.